geez you're gonna make me cry um
her her love was like a
a constant sort of blanket that i had
over me
that kept me warm that i could just
uh
think about and i could feel it all the
time and just being able to feel it made
me smile made me happy and made me know
that
no matter how things were
that
it'd be okay as long as i could go
and talk to her
this is kind of rough because my first
love dumped me like a month ago
and i'm sort of still going through that
but
she's a
really great person i think before i met
her
i had this idea of what love was
supposed to be because i had had a
long-term girlfriend before her
and i figured well
i guess everybody's just sort of uh
bearing through the the tough times and
then not liking your partner and that's
what love is is the ability to bear
through it but
now after i i met
my last girlfriend
i realized that love doesn't have an
upper limit
and you should really
be feeling it
even through the hard times you should
still feel it and you should still smile
when you think about her and i mean
that's why even now as much as it hurts
to not be with her
uh
i still smile when i think about her i'm
still
happy to see her succeed and see her
follow her dreams and
a real love
i think
will last forever even if you don't stay
with the person so
yeah
oh my first love
it's been
nine years
since
i've met him but the funny thing is
we're now in a relationship and i think
that he's gonna be the one that i'm with
forever
we met in high school
i was a sophomore and he was a freshman
and it was math class with miss batman i
just remember him
drawing shoes and it's really funny
because now he's a shoemaker he
makes boots for a living and wants to do
a bunch of other things
but i just distinctly remember him
wearing a green t-shirt
and
drawing in his little five-star notebook
and
he's making a pair of jordans that look
really cool
and
he was so quiet
and he seemed really awkward around me i
think i scared him well if you ask him
actually i think
i think he'd say that i was pretty
outgoing and i scared him like way too
much
and then over the course of the pandemic
we started talking and
started dating and it's been about a
year now and here we are i don't think
i'd ever want to be with anybody else
for the rest of my life it's funny i
always looked for him and everybody that
i knew
ex is terrible people
but i mean here we are we're here now
and i'm
really happy to be with him
and i hope that it continues to be that
way
oh
well
um if you want to hear it
um
my first love i was 14
and
we were madly in love
madly in
love i was in high school
and
she she took me for a walk in the rain
on black hill uh in morro bay
i knew right away
of
that i was madly in love with
we were together for four years
keisha
okay what's her name i i never
thought that we would never not be
together again i i was at a music
festival and somebody said
well that's your first relationship
it's it's not going to last and that was
crazy to me i i was like
we will be together
forever
no doubt but that's not how life works
and um
we stopped dating i stopped eating
and lost 60 pounds
because i i was just
so entrapped
in her love
my brother he passed away recently
and um
the one thought that i had was uh
well he never had a geisha you know
never
he never
had somebody like that i hope that
everyone has a first love
because it means the world it's
an essential
human experience to
fall in love for the first time
oh
god
it's so embarrassing
there was this girl in my class
i won't use her name just in case she
sees this and she gets embarrassed but
um
i
i just had recently realized that i was
gay and i was
a coward
so i had my friend come with me to
confess to this girl
and i guess because there were two
people she was like sure yeah and then
we like hung out the rest of the day
and then after school i get home
and she messaged me she was like i don't
actually like you i just felt too
awkward to say no
and it was like
so crushing because i was so into this
girl for so long and i was just like
i can't go to school tomorrow
laughing at me
my first love was i really believe that
this is my first love was it
kindergarten
his name is cody
and we kissed in the mcdonald's play
tubes and he got me a big stuffed bear
for valentine's day and our moms were
friends but our moms weren't friends
first they were friends because we were
in love
and i met him the very first day of
school
and um i don't know where he is but i
hope he's okay
how long did that relationship last
only kindergarten oh ended after
kindergarten because he fell in love
with another girl named laura
this is all true
were you heartbroken yeah there was a
big scene on the playground on the
blacktop
and i
had a circle of girls around us
and i said pick me or laura and he
didn't answer and then i threw a stick
on the ground and i said fiddlesticks
and i walked away
it was all true
that was the day we broke up
can you tell us how his love made you
feel
oh my gosh
um
his love made me feel
like i
was not six years old
but in fact eternal
okay my first love happened to me in my
life when i was 19 years old
ended up to be 55 years of a wonderful
marriage and he just passed away
november 3rd 2020. they're going to make
me cry
because he's going now
he cherished me he didn't expect me to
be a person who did everything for him
hand and foot he
pitched in and did things you know that
i think for sure that he was not taught
as a young boy to do because he was from
the era that where parents thought that
boys didn't cook boys didn't clean boys
didn't wash clothes boys didn't have to
learn to do that stuff but he did it he
just could do would do the best that he
could to help me further my education
and to become a teacher you know that
was my goal and i met my goal because i
had the type of husband who
just cherished everything that i wanted
to do as far as our marriage was
concerned and he allowed it without even
saying one word against it we put god's
number one and that's how we made it for
55 years
well i think my very first love was the
love of a dog
his name was leroy
i think it wasn't just my love it was
the whole family's love
when my parents got divorced i was five
years old and the story is
that they didn't really care about the
custody of the children they carried
they they fought more over the dog
how did that make you
feel well i think he was worth it
i think the children are more
problematic
oh gosh
um
i'm
like i feel like i'm totally not like
totally sure what love is
the movies tell you it'll it'll be like
a spark and you'll know
but then i like talk to my mom and she's
like no you have to be realistic like
um
and so i'm not really sure
but i think about how like people get
divorced and stuff and how people like
you know so often like think they found
it and like figured it out and they
didn't and that's just me overthinking
but like i think about that too like how
it's it's really hard to know
okay
my first love is a drug addict and i
hope he's alive somewhere
because i don't talk to him anymore but
i love him a lot
um
but you know you never know who it'll
come after so
you never know who they're gonna be
i met when i was 14 and we were married
for five years
i just kind of went really really fast
downhill
is it okay with you that i'm asking full
of questions yeah okay i mean it happens
to people it's really sad it's just life
though
you kind of have to get over it that
sounds super rude and cruel but
it's just part of the whole experience
bad [ __ ] happens
what was the hardest part of the whole
thing
um
like i feel like most people would say
like realizing that i can't fix him or
solve the problem on my own but i think
the hardest part was just like watching
your person hurt themselves over and
over again you can't actually do
anything
you can like
try to do stuff
but
um
no you're powerless
that's it so
just watching your person hurt sucks
if you could give advice to maybe other
people who are going through the same
thing
what would you want to tell them
um two things one is not your fault and
two
whether you've known the person since
you were 14 or you got married like two
years after you met you have no idea who
people are going to turn out to be
and that's just how it is that's the
risk you take of meeting people and
sometimes it turns out really good
sometimes it doesn't
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera make sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you'll
be notified every time i have a new
episode up and follow me on instagram
i'll be posting more on there as always
thank you guys for everything i love you
all and i'll see you next time